does it piss you off that the giant when
you were playing for the giants
you know they never won then you they
had some good seasons we went to one
super bowl
right but they but then when you leave
they win well you know what
it's time for everybody right an athlete
you you look great
on field you're still putting up great
seasons in the ring you're still you
know you look fantastic your body's in
great shape
but you know right you know that you've
missed that step or if you've lost that
step and it's going to
fall off that cliff pretty quickly that
happened that was the question
from a fan perspective probably because
i could have given you a couple of 1400
yard seasons and
honestly howard being in new york you
know i mean you i didn't see you here a
lot but i was doing media
for 10 years i was right down around the
hallway doing serious with my brother
and
all these other things were going on
we're going and they were they were
becoming more interesting to me
yeah and so i lost the passion to do
what i was
you know didn't made a professional
career out of because i was getting beat
up
i couldn't go home and play with my kids
because my knees were hurting and my
body was aching
and so i said you know i got all these
other opportunities let me do that and
to be perfectly honest
i didn't think we were close as a team
right to winning a super bowl as a new
york giant
you had a lot of good will in the sense
that hey you great player
people love you this and that so when
you retire you become critical of eli
manning
you know you're an honest guy you said
i'm going to talk about what i
you felt that eli wasn't playing up to
snob it wasn't even about him playing up
the snuff because he was
he was gradually and almost
exponentially getting better every
year after year after year but you were
frustrated with him because of course i
was
yeah of course because i was 31 years
old and at the end of my career and we
we were starting kurt warner who was
leading us on a you know
like you know a great season eli's first
year and then we replaced him and all of
a sudden
now at 28 29 i'm starting over with a
rookie quarterback who's going
to we know he's going to get there yeah
because he has the pedigree but he's but
it's whatever it was a stupid comment
right i was trying what was the comment
i was saying that eli's leadership skill
is because the way he talks and the way
his manner is it's funny
right it's it's not so awkward and and
i'm not saying that in the derogatory
way it's it's it's entertaining
right right i mean we'd have we we shoot
basketball on the in the in the
you know with our tape balls after we
did our did our ankles and we try to
shoot it into the
you know the trash can we'd always be
rejecting each other and stuff like that
one day i'm shooting at eli
butt ass naked comes and just rejects it
right in my face i'm like what are you
doing
but it was funny right right but that
that was how he engaged with folks
um but wasn't there two days later two
days later
right whichever one of these beat brag
guys
goes to eli and says tiki said your
leadership ability is comical
oh dear right it was taken out of
context unbelievably out of context and
he responded to it
what did he say you know tiki's made
that transition he's in the media he
doesn't you know he's forgotten
what what whatever it was he took him at
it it created
two silos my silo and eli silo
did you call him i i called him the next
day and what
and did you get a hold on i did not get
a hold of him i called him the next day
and said eli i apologize you know that
did not come out the way it was supposed
to
um i did not mean any offense and we
were fine
it was immediate it became a media storm
for
a week two weeks and then and then they
go through the season the ups and downs
of that 07 season we all remember it
they were
playing horribly uh at the end of the
year and then they hit that
spark right right they exactly
the new england patriots in the
preseason and the regular season end of
the season
they lost they hung with them right
right and it gave them
confidence and an ability a belief that
they could play with anybody
they carried that through the playoffs
and then beat the patriots in the super
bowl because the giant fans booed you
at some point because yeah right because
they consider you a a guy who retired
too early they're mad at you for
protecting your body
and retiring too early exactly and i
miss the super bowl
it's like it's like a a shakespearean
play are you hurt by that does that
affect your life
no not really when you walk around the
street do giant fans say you're a tiki
[ __ ] off
actually giants fans say i appreciate
what you did for us i think time
has made them realize you know what i
was just a great player and
and the only thing that ever hurts me is
when people are ignorant
and say things like you sucked or right
you were horrible or whatever the
diminished what i accomplished as a
player and what i did for the
for the for the new york giants for 10
years